- She's one of our favorites at this show.
Her new podcast is called Bunga Bunga.
It's about Italian
Dictator Silvio Berlusconi.
Because why not?
Sure, give it up for
Whitney Cummings everybody.
(audience applauds)
(upbeat music)
- Oh hi, hi!
(Whitney screams)
- So awkward.
- Hi everyone!
- You are so cute!
- I do look cute.
(Kelly laughs)
Don't I look cute?
I have not left the house in six months.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
So I just want everyone to take this in.
I just really wanna
appreciate this moment.
Oh, hey boys, hey boys, hey there.
- You're magical!
I feel like how you're energy just was,
was how everyone feels
about their life right now.
Your just out of your house.
- I've gone insane!
I mean, I've truly gone insane.
'Member Jack Nicholson
at the end of the movie?
That like me.
I just remembered to cross my legs.
I haven't been out of
the house in six months.
I was like, "Cross your legs."
It's the first time I've worn
a thong in truly four months.
(Kelly laughs and claps)
Have you guys worn one?
It's like sawing through my body.
I forgot how painful these are.
- Well, I'm sorry I'm wearing a patch.
I hurt my eye, some weird
infection, whatever.
- I saw it, we should get you that bird
and put it on your shoulders.
So you'll look like Captain Morgan.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
- I'll take the alcohol.
Okay, no, you're hysterical.
No but you have pets, right?
- I do, i have so man pets.
- Do you have any pets
with like, awesome things,
like Tico the parrot?
- I don't have a parrot like Tico.
Although I do look like a
tropical bird now with this vibe.
I have three dogs, I have
a pig, and I have horse.
So--
- You're like a farm girl?
- I am like a farm girl.
I feel like that equals one child.
Is that fair?
- It depends on the child.
(Whitney laughs loudly)
- So yes, I do have animals.
I love them.
It's like having kids, but
they can't, like talk back.
And you don't have--
- It's the best!
Best relationship.
- Yeah, you can't like,
you can put 'em in like a crate 'til--
- Right.
- Best version--
- Well, there are cribs.
But yeah.
( Whitney laughs)
- I guess it is similar.
No but Tico, have you been
trying to be an influencer?
I've seen this, I follow you.
You're hysterical.
- I am hysterical.
- You are, you are!
(Whitney laughs loudly)
I'm telling you, and I am being honest.
Like, in such a hard
summer for a lot of us,
it's such nice escapism.
Humor is so healing.
- So healing.
- I'm not joking, I literally
go on Twitter to find you,
just to read your stuff
when I'm having a crap day.
- I love you!
- No, 'cause it's funny,
and it's nice, and it's hopeful,
'cause it's like, "Okay, we're gonna laugh
again at some point."
- There's this narrative
that like, the country's so divided.
And everyone hates each other.
I don't believe that.
I think there is a lot of that out there.
But I think that, you
know, I love doing standup,
because you get a bunch
of people in a room
that don't know each other.
And probably voted differently.
And they can all laugh at
the same stuff, you know.
- That's how if feel about concerts.
I think when people--
- Yes, that's what music
does too, it brings people together.
And you know, so during this time,
I've been getting very risky
in some of the videos
and stuff we're making.
Just to try to make you
guys laugh at all costs.
Benton, my assistant has been putting
me in danger constantly, to try
to make funny TikTok videos.
- I was gonna say, you're TikTok videos,
the one with the wine
was one of my favorites.
When you were drinking--
- Well, all of
my TikTok videos involve wine.
But that one, I just drink it on camera.
Oh yes, there it is!
- This is my favorite.
- So this is a TikTok challenge,
where you try to like, sorta
like put the wine in your mouth
and the other person drinks it.
I didn't like it 'cause I like the wine
to get down my gullet
as quickly as possible.
(Kelly laughs)
And yeah, so Benton
keeps putting me in all
these like crazy dangerous
TikTok challenges.
Which a lot of 'em are
actually very scary.
And I have to tell 'em, "Look, you know
you're not in my will, right?"
If I die, I don't know why
you're tryna kill me to much.
Guys, my eyelashes just came out.
- Your eyelash just came out?
- Yeah, oops, I think I
need and eye patch too.
- You want one?
- I was so jealous
that you had one.
- You just wanted
to be like me.
- What do I do
if my eyelashes come out?
- You should just--
- Do I have to take
the other one out?
Do I look crazy?
- I actually can't tell.
- I mean, compare to you, probably not.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
- Compared to me, you look great!
- I'll just leave my eyelashes right here.
- Just leave 'em there.
- I have not left
the house in so long.
- Do you feel like
we're playing some kind of game,
where we're slowly
undressing when we lose?
(Whitney laughs loudly)
- Wait, speaking of undressing,
how's your dating life?
- My dating life is ridiculous.
Pretty usual, but it seems like the guy
with the bird single.
So I feel like I have
that, maybe on the horizon.
I started dating online in quarantine,
which everybody is doing.
And I have to be honest with
you, I'm not against it.
So you have to do first dates now
like on FaceTime, yah know?
Which I thought was
gonna be really annoying.
But it's my new favorite thing.
- I feel like that's awkward.
- No, 'cause you can see
the inside of their house right away.
You can see their bathroom
on the first date,
which you couldn't do
before, unless you're a--
- Psycho!
(Whitney laughs)
- She's gonna say psycho,
I was gonna say slut.
But--
- Okay.
- You're--
- Oh, I just thought
you meant creeping in their stuff.
Oh okay.
- Because I can't go to a
guys house on the first
date, 'cause I'm a lady.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
But this way, you can be like,
"Hey, like let me see your bathroom."
And you can go in, and
you can truly find out
if they actually dating someone or not.
'Cause a lot of times guys
will say they're single,
but they're still
getting out of something.
- There's a word for that, lying?
- Lying?
(Whitney laughs)
Show me your shower, I will tell you
if you're still in a relationship or not.
If there's one little
sliver of Irish Spring,
like a little piece of bark and that's it.
You're single, I believe you.
If I see some pink Bath and Body Works.
Moonlit path, shave, you're
still in a relationship.
I'm , you're blocked.
- Wait, so how is comedy going now?
'Cause like, can you still do comedy?
Do you go to, 'cause I remember last time.
This was such a funny.
You used to talk about, you're
a little bit of a germophobe.
You used to carry your own mic.
- Yes!
- So you were ahead
of the the curve.
- I can't believe
you remember this.
- We actually were talking
about it, because I
remember, like, she was way
ahead of the curve.
And I thought Howie Mandel,
you would get along.
(Kelly and Whitney laugh)
'Cause he's pretty much like that.
- Well, the last time I saw
you I was promoting a tour,
that unfortunately got canceled.
And I was talking about
how I was so neurotic,
because I brought my own
microphone to every gig.
'Cause I didn't wanna get sick.
So my tour has been canceled, as you know.
So much live stuff has been canceled.
I just book a bunch of dates.
We're gonna be doing comedy outside.
We're gonna be doing some
drive-in comedy shows.
I'm so glad you guys are clapping,
because we're trying so
hard to make this work.
- Yeah.
- Find a way
to come make you guys laugh,
and come to your city.
You, thank you, I'm a hero!
I agree!
(Kelly laughs)
I fixed America!
- I'm a surgeon!
- But you, I mean, as a
musician you perform outside
all the time?
- Yeah.
- And it's, it's not really,
it doesn't really come natural
to comedians, so I don't know what to say.
I'm like, "Bring your
Lunchables and your bug spray."
- Okay wait!
(Kelly laughs)
How have you been getting
human interaction?
I feel like you've been getting a lot.
(Kelly and Whitney laugh)
- I am so crazy, guys, I forgot
how to talk to human beings.
- No you don't, I watch
the podcast, you're funny.
So Bunga Bunga, tell us, yeah.
- What, what, yes, I'm just kidding.
- No you're Bunga Bunga, tell us about it.
And why?
It's so random.
- Yes, it's so random.
You're intro was like,
"Bunga Bunga, why not?"
Bunga Bunga: So I don't
know if you guys have heard
Wondery does these podcast.
Like, you've seen Dirty John, Dr. Death.
They do these like really cool
like murder mystery podcasts.
And they asked me to host one of them,
which is so weird because
men always tell me
they don't wanna hear my voice.
(Kelly laughs loudly)
Certainly, not more than five minutes.
This is an eight hour show.
So I tried to make
myself like, less shrill,
and kind of like sexy and
sultry when I did the narrating.
- Don't do that for you.
- It's really wasn't (laughs).
(Whitney screams)
The Fran Drescher impression.
And so, it's about this
guy Silvio Berlusconi.
Who is this dictator that did
all this incredible stuff.
Just listen to it, you'll
be the smartest person
at the dinner party.
If for nothing else, do it just
to be better than your friends.
- That's so cool!
How random, that you got
asked to do that, right?
- Well, it was very, very random.
He had lots of dalliances with women.
Some of them untoward, some of them,
he was kind of a sketchy dude.
So I think that bringing
me on, I found a way
to tell the story while
not judging him too much.
But also holding him
accountable for his behavior.
It's a really interesting story
about a man that abused his power,
and brainwashed a country.
And it's kind of a great way for us to all
like you know, ask more questions.
And as women, look at the men above us,
and say, "No thanks, cut it out."
- Yeah, and it's okay to say that.
- Yes, it is okay to say that.
- Yes, yes.
Well, be sure to keep
an eye out for Whitney's
Codependent Tour and
check out her new podcast.
It's called Bunga Bunga.
You can find it wherever
you get your podcasts.